[Music]
what is the best Dave Chappelle sketch
of all time get it started watch this
you've written four books now I've
written six books thank published for
what would you say is the overall
message of your books sir my message is
simple Jews homosexuals Mexicans ain't
Rebs and all kinds of different tanks
stick and I hate I guess you referred to
african-americans what exactly is your
problem how much time you got buddy well
when I start well first of all they're
lazy good-for-nothing tricksters
crack-smoking swindlers big-butt
heaven lied no breathe on all the white
man's their feet up all the chicken like
thanks they're the best dancers hey and
they state that I mentioned that before
yes I believe you're good sir
matter of fact my friend Jasper telling
one of them Coons came by his house to
take a sister up for a date he said look
here that there's my girl
anyone has sex with my sister it's gonna
be me
it's alright you just that one yeah it's
the quintessential Dave Chapelle sketch
I mean it's the last one in the first
episode it will got everybody talking
it's like provocative forever it will
always be in the national conversation
because it's just like it's a it's a
true American sketch it is so funny I
just think it is so good
I love because in the room Nate was
looking for a time code that like a part
of the sketch that wouldn't be
immediately offensive and the first
maybe the third word is the n-word
[Laughter]
the sketch ends with the guy's head
exploding and he's in the news right now
because there that headline up Gillian
he has promised that he's gonna have
another special coming out he was given
a speech recently what is the best
stand-up that you guys have seen
recently like Chappelle's specials or
something else recently that you've
really my buddy Casey James so Lango in
the whole wide world if we're gonna do
this personal shout I'm going to shout
out my best friend Adam Sandler you were
at my show recently you heard it here
first folks back funniest last week to
me I saw the drew Michael stand-up
special on HBO recently and I've been
thinking about that yes because it's in
like a black box with no no no audience
no audience oh oh I'm gonna Ramon I've
been thinking about that what's your
answer
I like my couch a special that was a to
me that was a very special special
that's what most people are going for
with the special whoa I'm sorry Bob I
need wood I like that song you know I
can get some music around here oh yeah
you can get it right there
Oh or you can get it right there
[Music]
hey Ron
so I will assume you have sex now cool
wanna see periscoping have sex with the
boyfriend yes I would alright
I don't know if that was her man
no granules that night vision you can't
really tell
I got see that one more time man let me
just see one more time I'll go in there
check it out and then I'll be right back
out all right that was her all right
later sell you she don't want to see any
have sex yeah I'm absolutely sure man
forget this to go to the Knicks game
Thanks alright I do a great doggie style
I know Ron okay I got my stroke from you
thanks everyone I'm done with the porn
what want to see you naked pictures
Halle Berry from swordfish of course I
Internet that's exactly how we'll be
because at one point that was very real
to me that sketch that was in high
school about and one point I mean
yesterday that was a very real Scout to
me I still still music a Nardo off the
internet it's just sitting there for the
day but you still still mom I got on my
computer I have no idea what wait but
isn't Napster a paid streaming service
that's right when that turned on us it
really it flipped the game upside down
the light it was so many ways to still
music but the point it of itself yes
that is such a specific time stamp of
what your internet was about the
internet right now it would just be the
first sketch that we watched
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah just be that yeah that's not a
great place now so there's a joke in
there it's two minutes and 55 seconds
later it kind of implies that Dave
Chappelle is just masturbated you know
it's pretty heavily implies from flaccid
to ejaculation how long is it boys
episode did this include finding the
correct clip because now you're going
out the door but you realize I need to
take care of this before you go to clip
you've already got it picked out all
right that's enough for them yeah my mom
watches the show your mom watches the
show you don't need a talk like this you
know talk about after Batian with your
mom absolutely not there's no way that
they're gonna watch this and be like
okay they're just saying times we have
to do it we just have to figure it out
so let's go good evening and welcome to
the first and maybe only Rachel grabbed
here in New York City folks this is for
all the marbles what happens here will
state the racial standing of these
Americans once and for all
that's right and the crowd is here to
support their racism well rob some of
the biggest names in sports and in
entertainment are on the line tonight
and I'm excited to see who's going to be
drafted by which race seated behind me
on the stage there are the various
representatives and believe it or not
the blacks have actually won the first
pick Wow that's the first lottery of
black person's won in a long time Billy
I'm guessing they're probably still
complain
now why don't we take a listen be in the
back delegation to attacker would no
surprises their religious and most
dominant athlete in the world
his father black his mother tie well it
doesn't matter anymore because now think
about it he's been discriminated against
in his time he's had death threats and
he dates a white woman sounds like a
black guy to me sometimes when we dive
into the comedy central vault we see
little things that we we wonder would
would this apply today such as the Dave
Chappelle subtle white face like powder
yeah that'd be fine that's so cool you
can go that way I can't dress as Chris
for Halloween or something you heard it
first next week I'm in white fees Chris
has been asking to do white can I just
come in as white faith in wondering
smiles but this one would this segment
would work better maybe if I was in
white must be little Tmart do i call me
daddy is it okay if I call you mr. deez
mr. deeds right I don't understand
you must be Leonard that's right should
I call you daddy
hell no all your mom calls me daddy boom
up top take my bag up to my room and if
I find a been going through my I'm gonna
be chin yeas understand
no no dinner cooking I don't make some
grits oh yeah I'm glad you asked little
buddy
this here is cauliflower this is corned
beef hash and these are parsnips what is
a parsnip just a little casual misogyny
it just goes to show that the old
premise of white people be like black
people be like when done well
still pretty funny cool my favorite part
of that sketch is when a Chappelle and
white face everybody and he says oh you
want to get naked his no I just put my
penis through the hole like pajamas he
just goes through the whole pajama be
regular you go pants off we do it the
cool way like you but how do you do it
it's not like a few my shoes on and just
lower my pants to my knees that'd be
weird
we could've mean that's how all Asian
people do it man Chappelle really brings
out some interesting conversation this
is called healthy racial Ryan I think
you got a shout out for us we do we have
a few shout out boy this was yesterday
on the show was the game where they
played expensive wine cheap wine or hot
sauce and it didn't work out well
specifically for these two gentlemen and
you know we have a couple shout outs one
coming from Willie this is the greatest
game ever we cool Billy washer 89 heroes
heroes all mostly Ryan though because
I did sneak onto the set and switch
Jordan's last wine shot glass with yet
another hot sauce Oh prankster man yeah
[Music]
yeah Jericho Jay says I feel like you
guys picked up johnny Knoxville as an
executive producer not mad about it and
then because I switched the hot sauce
and my mom does watch the show as you
said earlier my mom sent me a text and a
big shout-out to my mom well you did -
Jordan was mean Oh
what something tells me he would have
done it to you if the roles were
reversed and they wonder why the girl
asked why you were portrayed as a dick
emoji there was a girl there's a girl
that works you the things that I'm a
jerk on the show though you moved back
loving this but there you go that's our
YouTube shadow but respect we love you
respect respect respect respect respect
we love you made this is a cool voice
you're doing yeah man they're cool keep
watching you might see Chris and white
face one
[Music]